gonna go on uh hopefully no matter what
i think they're gonna have a few showers
though heading into that part of the
country
as we get to thanksgiving but for us it
looks like we
are gonna get a few more breezes by the
time we get to thanksgiving
so hopefully you don't plan on flying
any turkey balloons
as we get into thanksgiving there's tom
turkey right there
and that's our forecast for thanksgiving
we are looking for some breezy winds to
return
on thursday 44 by 8 am maybe you'll have
the turkey in the oven
by then 55 by noon and we'll look for
just under
60 degrees on thanksgiving thursday so a
little bit cooler
as we get to the holiday gorgeous skies
for your tuesday
it is nice out there nice and sunny but
it's brisk we've had breezes overnight
hence the nice clear skies but it is
extra cool
sunrise well it's happening 6 27 was the
official time
4 28 is the sunset and we've got just
about another
month of shorter and shorter days as we
get
to uh the winter solstice later in
december third week in december
so 45 and mountains edge 44 at
centennial hills look at 24th at kyle
canyon
where we have the breezes it is feeling
extra cool so please make sure you get
on a nice warm jacket
48 out at red rock and it's been windy
there overnight kingman's down to 39.
so we'll look for good sunshine today
and again temperatures
right about normal feeling a little more
seasonal 62 is normal and we're looking
at 63 today
and tomorrow as we get into thursday
another system does push its way
into the desert that's where we're going
to get the winds back and then a little
bit of cooler
air 59 on thursday back to 60 on friday
but a nice weekend we'll look for mid
60s on sunday
nice for leftovers if you have any i'm
sure all the pie will be gone but
nate maybe we'll have some extra turkey
left over
for some good turkey soup and sandwiches
through the week